[Music]
[Applause]
eli manning the two-time super bowl
champ and uh co-hosting an alternate
monday night football broadcast with his
big brother peyton
back on the program good to see you eli
when's the last time you had a true fist
fight with peyton
uh i don't know if peyton
and i have ever had a true fist fight um
you know there's been some wedgies given
uh from both sides of us that was
probably the most recent thing but you
know he's five years older than me so
you know uh peyton and cooper were two
years apart they definitely had the
fights me it was more i was just taking
the brunt of a lot of the harassment of
being the younger the younger child and
so now nowadays we're 40. he's 45. you
know he kind of knows better not to mess
with me anymore who would be more likely
to be able to play in a game this
weekend you or uh peyton
i think i gotta i gotta take that one
you know i uh
i think just
i saw him throw the other day we had we
had our our high school football camp
back in july and it was it was it wasn't
coming out uh real good so yeah and that
was throwing like a high school like
little ball so i think you get that nfl
ball i don't i don't think he's ready
how does brady continue to do it
i have no idea you know it's it's i'm
not
surprised by it but it's just i'm still
amazed by it
and what he was able to do last year uh
you know changing teams a new
organization after 20 years and you know
a new offense pick you know trying to
learn that offense in a shortened
offseason and and still get in there and
and create the same results so you know
i don't know
how he
you know does it himself but also how he
just convinces the team that they're you
know they're super bowl ready and
they're a contender and you know it
wasn't the fastest start they lost you
know week one he didn't play great but
you know he just got better and guys
rally around him the defense played
outstanding and and he's got something
where
uh he just has the ability to lead those
those guys uh to great things
all right now that you're an analyst i
can ask you this who's
a better quarterback
tom brady or
peyton
ooh uh currently today tom brady is
currently right right this second career
is that politically correct yes it is
you know
it's one of those deals you could you
could argue this over you know obviously
i'm a little biased to my brother
because i've seen it firsthand
uh just the way
you know he just you know he led that
team and made the players around them so
much better um but obviously you gotta
look at tom's
career and just uh you know winning
winning championships and and that's
what he's been able to do and you know
um and so you know who had a better
better career you can flip a coin or
who's a better quarterback
you know they're both amazing and and
you know you'd want any of them on your
team
uh to to lead a franchise for a long
time do you wear your super bowl rings
i do not i have not worn them in a long
time and uh you know they're just
they're they're big and now they're even
getting bigger i saw the ones from last
year i mean you can't even you you know
you you'd hurt somebody if you shake
someone's hand you're gonna scratch them
you'd hurt your own hand
they're they're getting too big i need
like a mini one then maybe i'm gonna
wear it you know what i brought this up
a couple of months ago why not have one
that's sort of like a class ring that
allows you to wear it all the time that
you still have that one you put away in
a safety deposit box how about we start
a business where we come up with
wearable super bowl rings
i'm i'm all in i think this is a this is
a gold this is gold jerry um you know so
i think i mean
i i agree you can't wear that thing and
oh now you're worried you might lose it
you know you take it off and so i think
yeah i guess getting one you can wear
yeah like your class ring that hey we
were the champions here's my here's my
mini my mini ring
all right give me your philosophy with
you and peyton doing monday night the
the alternate monday night broadcast
what's the game plan
game plan is just hey we're we're on our
couches in our living room watching
monday night football together we
haven't we haven't done that in probably
25 years has watched the monday night
football game uh together uh and you
know he'll be in denver i'll be in new
jersey but we're still watching the same
game or talking we're telling old
stories either about those teams or or
playing in us in that stadium or just
all sudden we hear certain words being
called in the game or we see a play and
we have a story so it's very casual it's
very just uh you know just having fun
we'll get to really analyze some of the
plays and talk them through but then
we'll also skip over you know a lot of
you know runs for two yards like we
don't need to discuss
who is carrying the ball for that two
yard run and and what happened so we'll
bring some guests in there uh to have
some conversations and so it's just it
should be a a fun way to watch a
football game and and learn a little bit
about kind of behind the scenes of
playing quarterback being in the nfl and
what's going on in the huddle what's
going on on the sideline what are they
looking at when they see the tablet
what's that offensive coordinator you
know yelling at that guy what you know
what did he do wrong what's going on in
all these situations talking to eli
manning won two super bowls of course
with the giants you once threw i think
six picks against the chargers
that doesn't sound not that i think
that's peyton peyton dude
oh
sorry about that um how would you as an
analyst
look at that performance let's say let's
take it away say i did it yeah i threw i
threw i think i threw i think my most is
four no but let's say you're an analyst
watching a performance where somebody
throws six interceptions
you know every every interception has a
story and you can you can have an excuse
uh the thing is nobody really wants to
hear the story you know the coaches
don't want to hear it
you know there's always receiver ran the
wrong route there's always hey this ball
gets tipped they you know uh you know
we're down i'm trying to force something
so yeah everyone has a story uh no one
really wants to hear it
and you know it's uh
sometimes they're just they're just
contagious you know the interceptions
can be contagious you start throwing one
you start thinking hey whatever you do
just don't throw another interception
and once you start thinking that way
they just keep coming it's like you
can't you can't help it they just you
you know
uh something bad is about to happen you
just can't pull it back yeah i i came up
with a stat called shared blame
interceptions sbi
that way i like it you know after the
game the receiver can say that's on me
it shouldn't be on you um before they
never say that they never they've never
said that
it's never happened before before i get
to uh your plug with verizon uh derek
jeter going into the hall of fame uh you
of course spent your career there in new
york how did you know you were wired to
be able to deal with new york
coming from new orleans
you know i i didn't know i think uh you
know i think i do have a little bit more
of a kind of a laid-back personality
where
you know things don't don't always
bother me if someone says something bad
about me you know i don't i don't take
offense to it i don't i don't hold
grudges it's not gonna ruin my day um
you know so i think just the ability to
kind of handle that new york media i
give i give peyton and and cooper a lot
of credit for them just beating up on me
all the time when i was growing up and
they said if you tell anybody or you
complain or you tell mom we're gonna
make it worse the next time so i just
said i was not allowed to complain or
cry or say anything about it so i could
just easily just forget about it i move
on and i'd see them the next day and
after they just gave me an atomic wedgie
and and or pulled down my pants in front
of you know a bunch of girls you know i
just you know i could still love them
the next day and be happy and and just
be okay in any situation i was in and i
think that's kind of prepared me for the
new york media and the new york and
dealing with the ups and downs kind of
never getting too high never getting too
low
they pulled your pants down in front of
girls
yeah mardi gras mardi gras
you know i'm i'm like hands up throw me
something mister you know it's just a
perfect situation just to come behind
and get the uh get the pants down i'm in
some you know old school tighty whities
you know
not not a good look
uh what are you doing with
verizon i've got the verizon 5g
multiview so uh verizon does a great job
of just the innovation the technology
during games at the stadium so they're
in they're in uh seven different
stadiums this year they're in vet life
so for giants games i'm going to the
giants game this sunday i'll be in
person and so if you log into the giants
app
they have the verizon multiview where
you have seven different camera angles
where you can watch replays you can
watch the game you can see you know hey
was this guy in on the sideline hey did
the ball cross the goal line to get that
touchdown so you don't have to wait on
the jumbotron for the for the replay you
can be right there on your phone uh
within that app and and kind of get all
the the cool angles uh you can be right
on the quarterback whatever however you
want to watch it so just creating that
in-game experience act while you're at
the game to give you all that technology
and features to even enjoy it more are
you wearing your jersey to the game
i was thinking about that i was i was
you know just this morning i was like
what am i going to wear
to the game i mean everybody now wears
jerseys do i wear my own jersey they
wear a saquon jersey you know i don't
know well nobody would think that eli
was wearing his own jersey
i've i've often thought about that but
but when you are then it looks weird
backfire you know you're like no that's
definitely him and you get busted
wearing your own jersey then it's like
what why what is he doing why would you
wear his own jersey but i i have
thoughts it's like yeah
no one would he's not to wear his own
jersey it can't be him we'll leave him
alone uh good luck with verizon and uh
good luck on monday night great to talk
to you again eli thank you
always dan good good being with you pal
that's eli manning
courtesy of verizon